[Music]
colton is with us in iowa city
hi colton how are you hey dave i'm well
thanks for asking that by yourself
better than i deserve sir how can we
help
uh yeah so my wife and i have been
struggling uh maritally
lately we've been married uh it'll be
six years this august and the fifth year
has been rough
one of the areas of stress are our
finances
uh we're in need of rebuilding
foundations
really we have a starter emergency fund
about 32 000 dollars in debt a mortgage
and uh income that's not always
predictable
so i've got some specific questions for
you but first i
just want to know like what do you
recommend to rebuild financial
foundations in our marriage
well i i
i think everybody has to have a voice in
the discussion
and uh sometimes that's what happens and
then the second thing that
that if everybody has a voice the voice
has to involve
um that as i use my my vote
in our marriage that my vote is not for
my selfish need or want my vote is for
the good of the overall family
that's how i'm using my vote and so it's
not like a little child in other words
stomping their feet
with a red face on the cereal aisle
demanding
frosted flakes because i deserve them
and sometimes we get that little kid
inside of us making our
adult decisions called selfishness
and then it affects our relationships so
couples that can
rise up above their own selfish desires
for the good of the overall family will
ultimately get their own selfish desires
but they also get unity then
and because there's some nobility to
that but the most most of the money
fights that sharon and i have had
uh involve selfishness on one of our
parts
usually mine
does that make any sense oh yeah
absolutely i just i
i got a a new craving for a new car
and that's been uh not so good for us
and so i totally get that yeah so that
kind of explains you know what's going
on with you
that's not a bad thing that you want a
new car the bad thing is is if you
actually acted on that
while you're 32 000 in debt and your
wife's scared to death because she's
worried
with the erratic income all the time if
you're going to have money for
electricity
and you come waltzing in with your muddy
boots going i just bought a new car
because i'm just the smartest guy on the
planet and she's going to slit your
throat you know that's what's going to
happen right
so that's that's what goes down you get
you just get angry
at that stuff but so you have to say hey
i'm going to get a new car
but the way i'm going to get it is i'm
going to live like no one else so that
later
i can live like no one else because i
got to clean this 32 000 up for the good
of myself and to go to this family
before i can even talk about a car yeah
i'm curious colin what's the family uh
household income
uh yeah so it is she brings home
probably around uh twenty 2800
a month that's after tax um
and then for for me i'm a worship leader
at a church as well as a wedding
filmmaker so
that is super sporadic um making 15 an
hour
um at the church so it sounds like about
40.
about 40 grand a year yeah yeah yeah
house like that
yeah yeah so i can see depending on how
many weddings that we book
because if we book weddings i can make
40 000 myself with just uh
uh fifteen or so weddings so what does
it what what would a typical case study
fight look like in your house
describe it to me about money a money
fight
yeah a typical uh fight i guess would be
i want to do one thing and she wants to
do
something else with money so for example
i want to say
uh invest a little bit of money she
don't want to do that she wanna
wants to be rigid and pay off debt or i
wanna pay off a debt but she's afraid of
uh not having enough money for next
month
um and so a lot of it's uh pretty
passive
passive aggressiveness we're not really
like
vocal at each other like that but um
yeah it can lead to some tension yeah
okay so
that's where um if you'll start doing a
detailed budget where every dollar
of your income for this coming month
has a name on paper has an assignment on
paper and you agree on where it's going
to go
and you're applying any extra money you
can find in the budget to the baby steps
and both of you are in agreement on that
concept
then what happens is all you're holding
each other accountable to
is what you agreed to and
that we're sticking to the baby steps
and what here's
here's exactly how this will go down the
first month
the first time you do a detailed budget
where every dollar
has a name it's gonna be a big fight
get ready you may need to actually stop
midway through working on the budget and
have a cooling off period and both of
you go for a walk around the block
separately because it's gonna drag up
all this stuff
okay it's gonna drag up all these
insecurities it's going to drag up all
these uh
feelings of inadequacy where maybe i
don't feel like i'm making enough money
or doing enough
it's going to it's going to drag up a
little selfish kid that's in the serial
aisle
all this stuff is going to come up but
if you can push all of that down
onto that paper and say the best way
for me to have the life i want which is
for my family to succeed
is to follow these steps and have a game
plan for the money
the best way for me to have security is
to follow these steps
then you're going to begin to get the
emotions under control the second month
you'll have there'll be some rough spots
in the discussion the third time you do
the budget the third month it'll
actually start to work
but i'm going to promise you some pain
between now and the third month
and and correct me from wrong dave
because i'm not married but
from a money perspective colton i would
suggest to help you
kind of ease that pain a little bit
maybe you and your wife talk about what
the success looked like for us
five ten years from now what is our
vision what are we
aiming for is it to be debt free is it
to buy a home
is it to go on a dream vacation is it to
build wealth and then once you
identify that success that vision then
the budget helps you get to that
then the budget and and will be like all
right is this gonna
if me buying a new car or is me doing
this is that helping us get towards
the next five to ten years and if you're
following the baby steps
you don't have to have a discussion
about whether to do investing or to do
debt you have debt we're working on the
debt there you go so we've we've both
submitted ourselves to this proven plan
yep and so all i gotta do is go
no it's not what the baby steps are
because we've agreed we were going to do
those
oh i guess darn it that's right so the
best way to get to investing
is to get out of debt but the best way
to uh get out of debt is temporarily
stop investing and so
the there's a reason the baby steps are
laid out the way they are and the reason
millions tens of millions of people have
done this now literally yeah that's not
an exaggeration
and so you just say all right i'm gonna
do this plan that has worked for so many
others we are gonna do the plan we're
both in agreement that we're gonna do
this plan
it's not like i'm going to do it make
you do it we're both in agreement
and then when that feeling rises up and
she says hey i feel insecure
i really want to start investing the
best way for us to get investing is get
this debt cleared let's keep hammering
the debt there you go okay or
you know i really want to or you're
thinking man i want to get a new car
well the best way to do that is get
clear of all this stuff
and have some wealth uh because you know
right now you're too broke to be buying
a car you know
and so you know you all of a sudden it
all starts to come very very
clear and you know some of your vision
can be little things i'll give an
example
when we were broke i clearly remember
sharing
and i arguing about the food budget how
much she was going to spend at the
grocery store
and she was mad i mean she because she
wanted more food
like yeah because i was not i was not
being forthcoming enough on that line
item
okay and she was she was hot you know
what sharon looks like she gets that
look oh yeah his
head gets [ __ ] a little bit yeah and so
you i mean you can see it coming right
and she says
you know someday sarcastically like he
said passive aggressive
i just hope we're rich enough that i can
just go to the grocery store and just
fill up the basket and i said you know
what
the best way for us to get there is to
stick the dadgum budget hey
and you know what today she will tell
you that story today she remembers that
fight too
are you serious because she says
sometimes i just go and fill up the
basket even though we don't need food
just because by god i can do it now
because we paid the price we lived like
no one else now and you fill up the
basket like no one is no so
maybe your vision is something just like
that yeah absolutely what was that that
was a sign of her insecurity
because i had screwed up and lost
everything and she's scared our family's
going to be hungry
that's what all that meant yeah it was
passive aggressive as crud as what it
was
this is the ramsay show